L
UNIVERSE.
WE HAVE THAT GOING FOR US.
>> WE CERTAINLY HOPE SO.
THE SYSTEM SEEMS TO BE
EFFECTIVELY WITH WHAT IS
GOING ON.
RACHEL, THIS IS WHAT I GET
CONCERNED ABOUT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE RUNNING THE
ADMINISTRATION, CLEARLY NOT JOE
BIDEN.
THEY THINK ALL OF THIS IS FINE.
THEY KEEP PUTTING HIM IN FRONT
AND KEEP ARRANGING, WHETHER IT'S
THIS KIND OF PRESS CONFERENCE
WHERE HE REFUSED TO TAKE MANY
QUESTIONS AT ALL.
THERE IS PEOPLE WITHIN THE
ESTABLISHMENT THAT ARE MOVING
THIS ALONG.
IS THAT SOMETHING WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT POST- NOVEMBER
AND THE MIDTERM?
>> OF COURSE.
THERE'S THREE YEARS LEFT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WE CAN PUT THE BRAKES ON IN THE
MIDTERM, BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE
DAMAGE THAT CAN BE DONE.
I DO LIKE THAT THIS GUY SLIPPED
UP.
WE WERE CALLED CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THE LIBERAL WORLD ORDER OR HAD
THE GREAT RESET.
WE KNOW IT'S TRUE.
THEY ARE TOTALLY WILLING TO
IMPOVERISH US.
IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY HAVE
AN OBSESSION WITH
ENVIRONMENTALISM AND THEY WANT
TO TRANSITION TO FOSSIL FUELS,
OUT OF FOSSIL FUELS AND INTO
ENERGY THAT WILL MAKE US MORE
DEPENDENT ON CHINA.
THAT IS PART OF IT.
IT IS BIGGER.
IT'S A GREAT RESET.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GIVE US WHAT
SCHWAB WANTS WITH THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM, WHICH IS A
CHINESE SYSTEM, A SOCIAL CREDIT.
A CHINESE TYPE OF CAPITALISM
WHERE THE TOP HAS CAPITALISM AND
WEALTH.
THE ELITE AND THE STATE AND THE
REST OF US LIVE UNDER SOCIALISM.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THE
CURTAIN OPEN UP AND STARTING TO
SEE BEHIND AND WE KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON.
>> SCOTT, DOES IT MATTER WHO
GETS ELECTED IN NOVEMBER?
THE VOLUME OF THE STATEMENT THAT
IS MADE IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
IN YOUR TIME IN WASHINGTON AND
AS AN AMBASSADOR, HAVE YOU FOUND
THE THING THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
POLITICIANS ARE WILLING TO DO,
LIKE LISTEN TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> IT WILL BE A VERY SERIOUS
WARNING SHOT ESPECIALLY LEADING
INTO THE PRESIDENCY.
EVERYONE IS SAYING THERE IS A
HUGE RED WAVE.
THAT IS TRUE IF WE DON'T SCREW
IT UP AND NOT UNITE BEHIND THE
CANDIDATE WHO MAY NOT BE YOUR
CANDIDATE.
IT'S A REPUBLICAN WHO MAY BE
APPOINTED BY RONALD REAGAN.
NOT YOUR 100% FRIEND OR ENEMY AS
HE WOULD SAY.
JUST GETTING BACK TO SOMETHING
THAT WAS SAID EARLIER ABOUT THE
PRESS.
MY WIFE IS A FORMER JOURNALIST.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR THE
PRESS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR JOB.
QUOTING BILL BELICHICK, HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE BETWEEN THE CUE
CARDS AND THE USHERING IN AND
OUT.
THE AMAZING HANDLING OF THE
PRESIDENT, IT'S EMBARRASSING,
DANGEROUS AND AFFECTING OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT HAS GOT TO STOP.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FARM TEAM WE
WILL GO TO HARRIS AND PELOSI.
WE HAVE SOME VERY SERIOUS ISSUES
AND WE NEED SOMEBODY STRONG TO
DEAL WITH THEM.
WE ARE NOT.
>> THIS IS JORDAN VALLEY WIECK
AND A SENSE.
DOESN'T BIDEN HAVING A LIST OF
PEOPLE THAT HE GOES TO, DOESN'T
THAT TELL US THAT THE MEDIA IS
COLLUDING WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND MAKING SURE
THEY KNOW A CERTAIN SOMEONE IS
PICKED ON AND CHOSEN FOR
QUESTIONS.
IT'S GOING TO BE EASY OR AM NOT
A HARD FOLLOW-UP FOR THAT PERSON
CAN BE TRUSTED.
ISN'T THAT PART OF THE PROBLEM
ESPECIALLY WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS CORPS?
THEY COMPLAINED ABOUT ACCESS.
HAVEN'T THEY'VE BEEN
FACILITATING THIS DEBACLE?
>> YEAH.
IT'S FUNNY WHEN YOU MENTION
ACCESS.
THE GUY WHO WAS PRESIDENT BEFORE
JOE BIDEN WAS THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE PRESIDENT THAT WE
HAVE EVER HAD.
HE TOOK MORE QUESTIONS AND HIS
THREE PREDECESSORS COMBINED.
SOME PRESS CONFERENCES WENT ON
FOR TWO AND A HALF HOURS.
THE PRESS COMPLAINED HE WAS
TRYING TO DESTROY THE FREE
PRESS.
COMPARED TO WHAT WE ARE SEEING
NOW IF THIS PRESIDENT HAS HAD
THAT LIST.
HE'S SMART ENOUGH TO SHARE THAT
THEY GAVE ME A LIST OF REPORTERS
THAT I HAVE TO CALL ON.
SAYING THE QUIET PART OUT LOUD.
IT'S NOT JUST JOE BIDEN.
AS FAR AS THE FARM TEAM, TRY
GETTING A FLIGHT SOMEWHERE THIS
WEEKEND WITHOUT IT BEING
CANCELED OR POSTPONED OR COSTING
YOU A FORTUNE.
WE HAVE A TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY WHO IS SUPPOSED TO BE
HAVING A PLAN WHO HAS NO
BUSINESS IN THIS POSITION AS
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY.
HE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO FIX THE
PROBLEM DESPITE HIS EXPERIENCE
AS A SMALL TOWN IN INDIANA.
THAT'S THE WHOLE TEAM IN GENERAL
IT'S NOT JUST BIDEN.
IT IS AMATEUR HOUR.
>> THE TWO PEOPLE THAT REPRESENT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND BASE,
REALLY ARE KYRSTEN SINEMA AND
JOE MANCHIN.
THAT IS THE ANSWER FOR THEM.
MY GOODNESS, THE CONDITION THEY
ARE IN